you can see between here and here it
goes up right I'm going if I were traces
out it would be going upwards ok but
then from here here's something weird
happens it's somehow drops down so I'm
kind of interested in how it does that
ok so I'm going to cover up parts of the
graph now and I want you to help me
think this through I'm asked to focus
just on this tiny tiny bubble wrap here
okay just break her out the rest of it
for a second I'm only interested in what
happens in this tiny spot ok remember
tan is I'm sorry green on pink green /
pink tell me is green getting bigger or
smaller as you go from that to run it
skinny bigger not know he's fast but
it's getting bigger ok so the numerator
that's the top let's write this sine X
that's the numerator in cos x is the
denominator sine X is getting bigger
it's getting bigger all right have a
look at the pink crap that's cosine
that's the denominator what's happening
to that guy he's dropping like a rock
right he's going down towards zero he's
getting smaller and smaller than sport
ok now I want you to think about
fractures for a second let me give you
some actual numbers so you can think
this through let's think about what
happens if the numerator or a fraction
gets bigger ok so for example if i gave
you like 1 over 20 and then I made the
numerator bigger to over 20 and in 30 20
and then for over 20 you can see these
fractions are progressively getting
bigger do you agree with that these guys
are all bigger than the previous ones
what happens if I do the reverse right
if I get the denominator and make it
smaller ok so for instance if I started
1 over 20 I'll make the dough no smaller
make it 1 over 19 then 1 over 18 then 10
17 no this is not so obvious but i think
is to work it out as I go from left to
right what's happening through these
fractions they are also getting bigger
right if I keep going you're going to
get like to a third and then to a half
and then ovation I'm going to get to one
right these guys are clearly bigger than
these guys you see ok
watch numerators getting bigger
denominators getting smaller in the
graph that we're looking at for this
tiny little section both of these are
happening at the same time okay so you
told me this makes it bigger and this
makes it bigger so if they're boys
happening what do you expect it's
getting a lot bigger right it's like um
it's like two people I try to like fill
up a bucket right and one person's
filling up the bucket that's this guy
the buckets getting heavier and the
other guy is also filling up a bucket
making it heavier so it's going to get
heavy really really fast okay it's gonna
give me know what does that mean for
this guy okay what that means is here
the graph I know it goes through here
right there's my ex it's going to get
bigger and bigger and bigger be it's
gonna take skyrocket okay now before I
put those in you to ask one more
question let's come back to the whole
graph net10 is green of a pink green /
pink red / pink what's the pig graph
equal to have 90 degrees C equal to 0
why do we divide by zero calculator at
least my calculator tells me if it's
still doing the same thing I did half an
hour ago is that when I do any number
you like like say 1/0 ok it says mmm not
very happy right it doesn't give you
zero don't even give u infinity he says
forget it it doesn't work okay you can't
divide it up a zero i won't go into the
details now of why you can't do it but
they are very very good reasons why you
can't it's not just the calculators are
lazy okay so all that means is for us
our graph remember from this little
section we were just looking at that
second in there it gets bigger and
bigger and bigger bigger but it can
never actually go to 90 degrees right so
I want us to indicate that by where's
black poop no seriously there is we're
going to indicate that by drawing a
vertical dotted line through 90 degrees
okay so it's going to look like this now
this vertical dynamite has a special
name and i'll tell you it in a moment
are you don't need to worry about the
name right now you just need to get it
on the dyno first so there's my downline
this dotted line is a vertical line or
vertical lines have the same kind of
equation namely x equals whatever number
they go through and then this one dress
through 90 degrees all right we're ready
to draw this thing at least in this
small section of here now remember from
0 to 45 degrees it's getting bigger like
so it's going up and you can see there I
hit that X which I knew about before
okay and then this thing happens right
the numerator gets bigger the
denominator gets smaller the whole
fraction starts skyrocketing like that
okay now you can see I draw Tamara bed
indicator keeps going right it can never
actually get to that dotted line because
as you just seen you can't divide by 0
things break down okay but you can get
closer and closer and closer you just
can't hit it right you can put in eighty
nine point nine nine nine nine nine nine
nine degrees if you like you're
calculating quite fine with that I can't
put in 95 just exploit okay now remember
how I said 0 / 0 that's not good Dimpy
there's another time when tan tries to
divide by zero can you see it where is
it can you tell me the angle it's 270
isn't it the pink graph is zero again
all over again right so therefore here
I'm going to get that same dotted line
I'm going to tell you what the name of
these things I do these things I'm call
and I'll write it down after i drop this
dotted line for you these things are
called big fancy name do you read that
asymptotes there's a silent p right
there in the middle asymptotes these are
lions that the graph approaches and gets
closer and closer and closer to okay the
equation of this one is again an x
equals something whatever it goes
through and that's 270 degrees x equals
90 degrees execution study those are the
equations for our asymptotes and you can
see I have a copy in here of what's
happening over here remember it went up
like so and then it's going to keep
going up higher and higher and higher
it's the same situation up here as I had
over here just upside down okay so it's
going to keep on going up both the
negatives cancel which is why it's a
positive okay you see down here free /
pink will be negative divided by
negative so you don't adopt any
negatives now I want you to try and
predict have a look we have a lot of the
graph on there in fact we have exactly
half of the graph on there we need to
fill in the other half what would you
guess that it looks like remember i've
got an x their next step I'm going to
conclude it's going to go opposite way
you see here I've got green / p a
positive divided by negative which is
negative right so I'm going to get the
same thing here I'm going to pass
through that X I'm going to go down you
can see I approach this x equals 90s and
tow it from the left to going off and I
approach it from the right going down
okay and I got the same shape yeah
All Right see that weird black graph
that we've got in there that is the
graph of y equals 10x sign over cause
let's notice a few things about it okay
firstly it's got these weird guys right
asymptotes the graph has bricks in it
that's really weird okay secondly you
can see remember that sine and cosine
their periodic we said it just repeats
over and over again 10 is periodic as
well but it's a different kind of
periodic sine and cosine are periodic
every how many degrees 360 that's how
long I have to go around the circle
until I get another copy of the same
thing right but you have a look at this
it's a bit sticky right can you see
let's get my piece of paper yet can you
see that have a look at that shape have
a look at it really carefully have it
singed in your mind okay now have a look
at this shape does it not look alien
from nought to 180 is exactly the same
as from 180 to 360 okay so this guy is
not periodic every 360 degrees in fact
is periodic every 180 degrees right and
all the way of seeing this is you can
see that guy right see that guy there I
could copy him and I could move him over
to here right I guess it would go
something like this up like that which
ever chunk of 180 degrees you take
you're going to get that copy over and
over again okay